are you tired of feeling exhausted
lacking motivation or struggling to
maintain your Edge recently as we age
our testosterone levels naturally
decline leading to various changes in
our bodies this decrease in testosterone
can result from factors such as hormonal
imbalances lifestyle choices stress and
the natural aging process
lower testosterone levels May contribute
to reduced energy muscle loss decreased
libido and changes in mood
understanding the cause behind the
declining testosterone levels can help
us address and manage these changes
effectively regardless of the cause
there are many natural options to
consider when aiming to boost
testosterone levels hello and welcome to
Med simplified I'm Dr Umar Malik and in
this video we'll be talking about three
traditional Indian herbs that have been
scientifically proven to increase
testosterone levels we will explore the
scientific basis behind the chemical
compounds present in these herbs and
we'll try to understand how they
increase testosterone levels in our body
in the end we will also look at a
practical way to include these herbs in
your diet so without wasting any further
time let's begin with the first herb on
the list that is shilaji shilajit is a
very famous herb derived from the
Himalayan Mountains it has gained a lot
of recognition for its potential to
boost testosterone levels naturally
shilajit contains various chemical
compounds such as fulvic acid dibenzo
Alpha pyrones and minerals like zinc and
magnesium which contribute to its
testosterone enhancing properties
folic acid which is a key component
found in shilajit has shown promising
effects on boosting testosterone
production in the body
fulvic acid achieves this by increasing
the release of luteinizing hormone in
the body which in turn triggers the
ladic cells in the testes to produce
more testosterone
furthermore the presence of zinc and
magnesium in shilajit provides essential
nutrients that support optimal
testosterone production and overall
hormonal balance
with its unique blend of compounds
shilajit offers a natural and holistic
approach to elevate testosterone levels
promoting Vitality energy and well-being
in men
a clinical study done in 2015
investigated the impact of purified
shilajit on male androgenic hormones
specifically testosterone the study
involved healthy volunteers aged 45 to
55 years old who were divided into two
groups one group received 250 milligrams
of shilajit twice a day for 90 days and
the other group was given a placebo
the result showed that treatment with
shilajit significantly increased total
testosterone free testosterone and
dehydroepy androceron levels compared to
the placebo group
furthermore the levels of luteinizing
hormone and follicle stimulating hormone
were also well maintained throughout the
study
these findings confirmed that shilajit
has potential benefits in enhancing the
male androgenic hormone levels
number two ashwagandha now let us talk
about ashwagandha a plant known for its
stress relieving qualities as several
Health advantages
ashwagandha also known as vidhania
somnifera or Indian ginseng has been the
subject of numerous scientific
investigations for its ability to
support hormonal balance particularly
testosterone levels Research indicates
that with analytes present in
ashwagandha can stimulate the production
of luteinizing hormone from the
hypothalamus in the brain
luteinizing hormone acts as a messenger
and stimulates the ladic cells in the
testes to produce more testosterone
additionally ashwagandha has been found
to reduce cortisol levels in the body a
stress hormone that can negatively
impact testosterone production by
reducing stress and promoting hormonal
balance ashwagandha supports healthy
testosterone levels leading to improved
energy strength and overall well-being
in men
number three safed musli
safed musli is a plant which is well
known for its aphrodisiac and
testosterone boosting qualities and it
is now being marketed as an herbal
alternative to Viagra
numerous scientific research has
investigated the chemical makeup of
safed musli and how it affects
testosterone levels
basically safed musli contains chemicals
known as saponins which are known to
promote the release of luteinizing
hormone from the brain and improve the
overall testicular function
a study was conducted in 2013 in India
to evaluate the effects of safed musli
on semen quality and testosterone levels
in healthy adult males the research was
conducted as a randomized double-blind
placebo-controlled trial on participants
aged 20 to 40 years old the participants
were divided into two groups with one
receiving the safed musli extract and
the other receiving a placebo for 12
weeks assessment of semen volume sperm
count sperm motility and serum
testosterone levels showed significant
improvements in the group that received
safed musli extract compared to the
placebo group based on these findings it
was concluded that the faith mostly
effectively improved male sexual health
and this study confirmed the traditional
claim that the extract of this plant
improves male sexual health by its
effect on semen quality and testosterone
levels now consuming three different
herbs individually can present a lot of
challenges and it can be time consuming
inconvenient and difficult to
incorporate into your daily routine the
easiest way to consume these herbs daily
is to take a single formula that
contains all these herbs and I will
included a link to one such product that
in my opinion is of very good quality it
is from this company known as man
matters and it contains all these herbs
in appropriate quantities and no one not
sponsored by these guys it's just that I
have used this product personally so I
can recommend it to my viewers
confidently
in addition to using these herbs there
are several other options to consider
when aiming to boost testosterone levels
these include regular exercise
particularly strength training and high
intensity interval training maintaining
a healthy weight managing stress levels
getting sufficient sleep optimizing
vitamin D levels and ensuring an
adequate intake of essential nutrients
like zinc and vitamin A also minimizing
alcohol consumption and cigarette
smoking goes a long way in having
balanced hormone levels including
testosterone this concludes today's
video we sincerely hope that this
scientific investigation of testosterone
boosting herbs was both educational and
practical for you if you found this
video helpful I humbly request you to
support our channel on patreon.com
methsimplified we typically don't work
with sponsors but making these videos
requires a lot of research writing and
animations which all cost us money now
you can help us improve our content with
just a small donation on our patreon
page and as a token of our appreciation
patreon offers exclusive perks to our
value supporters such as Early Access to
videos behind the scenes content and the
opportunity to suggest topics for our
future videos you can find the link to
our patreon page in the description box
down below thank you so much for
watching and remember to stay healthy
and stay curious